let's get back to the breaking news
we've been following all morning the
passing of sheldon adelson the
one of the biggest players in las vegas
gaming dying this morning at the age of
87 from the sans corporation
we're joined live this morning by
someone we talked to a lot about gaming
in las vegas unlv professor david
schwartz
joining us by phone this morning for
some perspective on the impact of
mr adelson and the sans corporation here
in las vegas
uh david it's good to talk to you again
this morning thanks for having me
joining us by phone so just let's just
talk broadly about the impact
of sheldon when he took over the sands
corporation back in 1988
what his company what he is uh his
impact here in las vegas
well at the time the fans was one of the
more respectable one of the older
casinos
when he tore down to build the venetian
he really helped to
set that model of the casino as a place
not just for leisure travelers and
gamblers
but also for business travelers and
really he was responsible
responsible for the boom in business
travelers that we saw
in las vegas right up until the pandemic
because
we think of of cocorian win
obviously the major players back at that
time in las vegas a very transformative
time
what kind of of a legacy is left by
sheldon adelson and his time with sands
and his time in las vegas do you think
well he really did show better than
anybody that conventions and business
travel could be a viable
business strategy for casinos you know
before that
before the venetian a lot of casino
owners looked down on it
and said well it's okay it fills the
room so they don't gamble
and mr adelson showed that even if
people aren't gambling
they can spend a lot of money in las
vegas and i think that really was ahead
of its time
he was obviously a successful business
and businessman but not without his uh
i guess critics one would say uh he
wasn't the biggest fan
of the unions in town uh what what
impact did he have on that aspect of las
vegas like maybe
beyond business but just on a on a
relationship level and
a more personal level yeah you know he
was somebody who has beliefs
and put his money where his mouth is and
i think even his harshest critics would
have to respect that
and when times were tough during the
pandemic he did step
up and did help to support his employees
so i think he definitely at least
definitely leaves behind a legacy of
somebody who certainly had some opinions
that not everybody agreed with
but did what he thought was right no
doubt about that uh professor schwartz
hopefully we can talk a little bit later
we're under a bit of a time crunch but
thank you for joining us on short notice
this morning to talk about this news
we appreciate it very much take care of
yourself